Welcome back.
I will be eating turkey in a
little over an hour, and I
want to work up an appetite.
So I will move forward and
continue with the SAT
problems. Today is Thanksgiving,
by the way.
That's why I'm a little extra
excited about the turkey.
Problem number 1.
Oh, by the way, we're on
page 47, section 9, of
the-- what's it called?
The official SAT study guide.
Problem number 1.
There is the same number of boys
and girls on a school bus
when it departs from school.
So at the beginning,
boys equals girls.
I don't know if this is
going to be useful
for me to write that.
At the first stop, 4 boys
get off the bus
and nobody gets on.
So stop one, minus 4 boys.
After the first stop, there
are twice as many girls as
boys on the bus.
So now, girls is equal
to 2 times the boys.
How many girls are
there on the bus?
So you could almost do
this by inspection.
But what you could say is, well,
here the boys is equal
to the girls.
Then we subtract 4
from the boys.
So this b is actually
a different b.
This is 2 times the new
one, b minus 4.
Why does that make sense?
We start off with b boys.
At the first stop, 4 get off.
So now there are
b minus 4 boys.
And at the end, it says that
there are twice as many girls
as there are boys now, and b
minus 4 are the number of boys
there are now.
So now girls is equal to
2 times b minus 4.
But we also know that girls is
equal to this initial b.
So you say b is equal
to 2b minus 8.
I just distributed the 2.
And then if we subtract b from
both sides and add 8 to both
sides, you get 8
is equal to b.
And you could have probably
thought about that.
I mean, you didn't have to do
all this fancy algebra.
You could have just said, well,
when 4 boys leave, I'm
left with half as many
boys, right?
Because before, I had just
as many girls as boys.
Then 4 leave, and I
have half as many.
Because now the number
of girls is doubled.
So if I have some amount of
something and when 4 leave,
I'm left with half, then we
know we started with 8.
So you could have just done
it without the algebra.
But this is one way you
could make sure you
had the right answer.
But it probably would've taken
you too long, so the best way
might have been just to
do it in your head.
Problem number 2.
And I will do it in magenta.
Which of the following is the
graph of a linear function
with a negative slope and
a positive y-intercept?
So I'm not even going to
look at their choices.
It'll take me forever
to draw them.
I'm just going to draw my own
graph that describes what
they're saying.
soon.
That's the x and y-axes.
And so they say, graph
of a linear function.
So linear function means it's
going to be a line.
Negative slope.
So negative slope means that it
goes from the top left to
the bottom right.
Because we move to the right.
Negative slope means that the
graph's going to move down.
So it's going to be a negative
inclination.
And a positive y-intercept, so
that means it intersects the
y-axis in the positive y area.
So a suitable line would look
something like this.
It would intersect here
and move down.
So it would look like this.
And if we look at the choices of
which ones do that, well, D
is the only one that looks
like what I just drew.
So the choice is D.
Problem number 3.
Refer to the following price
list. So I guess for
problems 3 and 4.
So let me draw the price list.
So number of donuts.
I can never spell donuts.
I always want to write
out dough.
And then it says, total price.
It says if I get 1 donut, it's
going to cost me $0.40.
If I get 6 donuts, a box of 6,
it's going to cost me $1.89.
And if I get 12 donuts, it's
going to cost me $3.59.
And the question is-- question
number 3-- of the following,
which is the closest
approximation of the cost per
donut when one purchases
a box of 6?
Well, a box of 6 costs $1.89.
So it's literally $1.89
divided by 6. $1.89/6.
And you can eyeball that.
It's a little over $0.30.
If it was $1.80, it
would be $0.30.
And then you have to have
9 divided by 6.
So it's like 31 and 1/3 cents.
It's approximately $0.31.
And if you look at it, they give
you very rough numbers.
So it's choice B.
And what they wanted you to
do is do this quickly.
They don't want you to actually
divide the numbers.
They want to say, well, $1.89
divided by 6 is roughly $0.30.
You do that problem really,
really fast.
Now, problem number 4, we use
the same price list. What
would be the least amount of
money needed to purchase
exactly 21 donuts?
Well, if we want to purchase 21
donuts, we want to get it
in kind of as big chunks
as possible.
So let's see.
If we got 12-- exactly
21 donuts.
It could've been tricky.
Maybe 24 donuts would've been
cheaper or something.
But we want exactly 21.
So we want to get one dozen of
this, because this is going to
be a little under $0.30
per donut, right?
Because $3.60 would be $0.30.
And then we want to
get 1 of these.
get-- let's see.
6-- that would get us to 18.
you
And then we want to
get 3 of these.
Times 3.
So let's see.
It would be 3 times $0.40, which
is $1.20, plus $1.89,
plus $3.59.
So 9 plus 9 is 18.
1 plus 2 plus 8 is 11, 16.
And then $6.68.
And that is choice B.
This is for problem number
4, not problem number 3.
Let's move on.
And we'll switch colors.
Number 5.
I think I'm going to have
to do some drawing now.
The figure above.
Which of the following
is closest to h of 5?
Yeah, I'll have to
draw that one.
So let me draw the
coordinate axes.
That's my x-axis.
This is my y-axis.
Let's see.
The graph does something
like this.
Let me draw the markers.
So this is 2, 4, 6, and so on.
And this is 2, 4,
6, and so on.
This is minus 2,
minus 4, so on.
And the graph looks something
like this.
So it's minus 6.
Let me do a different color.
So if we start at minus 6,
and then it crosses.
It goes someplace like
there, roughly.
Then it dips down to here.
Dips down something like that.
And then it does something--
I'm trying to be exact,
because this is actually all
dependent on the graph.
It's going to be something
like that.
And they want to know, after
I've drawn this graph, they
want to know, what is the
closest to h of 5?
Well, this is h of x.
This is 5.
So h of 5 is just going to
be this point right here.
And if we go to the left, it
looks like right in between 2
and 4, right?
And what's right in
between 2 and 4?
Well, 3.
And it looks even more like that
when you look at it on
the graph they drew.
My graph, you could argue
it's close to 2.
But when you look at the one in
the book, you can see that
it's close to 3.
And I have a minute
left, so I will do
that in the next video.
See